[Musique]
voilà jean ziegler salut bonjour
des livres des aventures des voyages un
fil rouge qui ressort l'ordre cannibale
notamment dans ce dernier livre est donc
plein d'autres la haine de l'occident
l'anticapitalisme à travers le
capitalisme explique à ma fille qu'est
ce que l'ordre cannibale
l'idée forte d'une part le livre
s'appelle le capitalisme et de fugue à
ma petite fille en espérant qu'elle
enverra la fin le capitalisme est un
paradoxe le capitalisme qui règne sur
ces planètes et qu'il était vaste et
certainement le mode de production le
plus dynamique plus créateur le plus
vivante que l'humanité ait connu
c'est une c c'est tout à fait vite ans
d'alchimie valoir un nouveau médicament
molécule n'est tous les quinze jours à
wall street un nouvel instrument
financier n'est tous les trois mois à
dynamique totalement extraordinaire qui
crée des richesses fantastique comme
l'humanité n'a jamais commis et en même
temps ce même mode de production
capitaliste à imposer à cette planète à
l'ordre cannibale comme théo viens de le
dire quand elles valent je vous donne
quelques chiffres tout les 5 secondes un
enfant dessous de 10 ans meurent de faim
de ses suites immédiates de milliards
d'êtres humains n'ont pas accès à
récuser à l'eau potable nocifs
tous les quatre minutes quelqu'un perd
la vue par mu par le manque de vitamine
a et des épidémies depuis longtemps
longtemps vécu vaincu par la médecine du
massacre des centaines de millions de
personnes dans le monde sont aujourd'hui
5,3 milliards d'êtres humains sur terre
la banque mondiale nous dit que si la
nourriture était normalement
équitablement distribués
on pourrait nourrir tous milliard
d'êtres humains presque double de
l'humanité autrement dit pour la
première fois dans l'histoire des hommes
aujourd'hui
il n'ya plus comme si c'est mal tu te
manque objectif de déséquilibre
l'objectif entre les besoins essentiels
à satisfaire et les biens nécessaires à
ces satisfactions c'est l'inégal
distribution tu es bien sûr c'est un
planète qui tue un enfant qui meurt de
faim aujourd'hui à mont saint bruno
parent est un enfant assassiné l'ordre
cannibale du monde est faite de main
d'homme il a eu très très minces
oligarchie transcontinental je vais pas
vous en vouliez a eu des chiffres mais
tv mais tout à leurs gentils avec elle
que quelques statistiques les 500 plus
grandes sociétés transcontinentales
privé tous secteurs confondus de
l'industrie commerces banques et ses
îles 500 plus grandes sociétés
transcontinentales et du monde ont
contrôlé l'année dernière 50 2,8 pour
cent dont plus de moitié du produit
mondial brut 10 de toutes les richesses
produites sur cette planète
ces sociétés ces oligarchies du capital
transcontinental privé ont un pouvoir
aujourd'hui comme jamais un roi femme
est un empereur sa mère pape n'a eu sur
cette planète
ces oligarchies impose mémo états les
plus puissants du monde à l'humain et
qui en tient aux par la planète entière
une pique tacul qui fonctionne selon un
principe très simple
ceux qui détiennent le capital ces
oligarchies mince infiniment riche les
85 militaires les plus riches de la
terre
autant de bien que 4,7 milliards à
moitié la plus pauvre de l'humanité une
inégalité comme les a jamais existé sur
cette planète
eh bien ces dictatures des autres gars
qui fonctionne selon un principe très
simple maximalisation du profit dans le
temps le plus court et à n'importe quel
prix en conséquence
ou bien nous détruisons ce système
maintenant et nous pourrons le faire ça
je vais te le dire
malgré des doutes tout à fait
inapproprié alors c'est pas des 12 non
non non non non c'est pas des doutes je
me pose il ya urgence
ou bien c'est nous qui des cuissons
maintenant ce système au retrait c'est
hors de cannibale du monde ou bien ils
nous détruit y compris la planète y
compris l'humanité alors merci gentil
clair c'est clair le message y passe la
question n'est pas de savoir on présage
passe ou pas moi j'aimerais poser une
question simple que je pense beaucoup de
gens je pense dénoncer c'est facile
alors quelle idée l'idée de dénoncer
pourquoi dénoncé jean paul sartre a dit
combattre connaître l'ennemi combattre
et nuit
cet ennemi qui domine cette planète ces
soldats fils capt'ain financier
globalisés ont créé une idéologie
capitonné nos propres consciences c'est
la folie de la pensée néolibérale qui
dit désormais il n'y a plus d'homme
qu'il faut d'histoire il a le marché ya
une seule instance régulatrice de la
planète qui est la main invisible du
marché est les forces du marché
fonctionne selon des lois naturelles et
tout ce que l'on peut faire c'est de se
soumettre de s'adapter de ville
fonctionnelle palabres et ses forces du
marché ce qui induit dit est de notre
propre impuissance
mon ami pierre beaulieu a dit le
néolibéralisme c'est comme le sida pas
volu du les forces immunitaire et
ensuite ils pu complètement let le sujet
par an d'où dénoncé ce sera toute la
nécessité ce que vous faites que fêter
dick sa fin c'est pour ça qu'on est là
il s'est magnifiquement que les intérêts
elle doit faire connaître l'ennemi
arracher le masque du visage hideux de
l'énergie montrer que c'est l'homme qui
fait l'histoire l'homme et les femmes
bien sûr fait l'histoire et non pas tes
forces aveugles du marché qu'il n'ya pas
d'impuissance fortement démocratisée
nous discutions rompu rassure pékin
pékin ce différend
ici à genève au coeur même de ce pays
magnifique et en même temps très
critique des corrompus et bien là les
sommes et les femmes ont toutes les
forces
tous les moyens en main et était à
abattre dix lots j'y serai triste le
gâchis et abattre les structures
présentes quand je crois que on est sur
la même longueur d'onde sur le fait
il ya des gros problème et tout le monde
le dit maintenant dénoncé la réponse a
été donnée il faut éveiller les
consciences mais il ya une autre une
autre option c'est de proposer et c'est
ça qui est génial dans l'esprit ted et
les ses petites soeurs tedx c'est qu'il
ya une myriade de propositions on parle
de bacchanales d'idées on parle d' idées
utiles à diffuser et alors en face on le
voit dans ce livre la proposition l'idée
forte c'est qu'il ya un mur le mur du
capitalisme qui bloque le la diffusion
large de ces idées qui fait que ces
idées au final elles vont pas très loin
alors qu'est ce que c'est ce mur bon
d'abord de che guevara a dit les murs et
plus puissante s'effondre pas des
fissures et des fissures apparaissent
partout parce que ce qui n'est
maintenant sous nos pieds c'est une
nouvelle société civile plane était
beaucoup plus puissants que l'état
national mourant beaucoup plus puissants
que les syndicats qui sont très
estimable une myriade cette fraternité
de la nuit mystérieuse cette myriade de
sociétés mouvements sociaux amnesty
clean pis le mouvement des femmes le
mouvement via campesina et c'est un fait
murmurer myriade de mouvements sociaux
enfin il existait déjà il existait déjà
alors pourquoi pourquoi est-ce que ça
bouge pas autant pour qu'est-ce que sa
finale formidablement alors d'accord
mais formidablement il ya même qu'il ya
de plus en plus d'inégalités non bien
sûr l'or mais c'est quoi ce mur de
capitalisme quelle idée forte qui sort
qu'est ce qui fait que ça bloque hyde et
reviendront d'accord viennent parce que
nous n'en verrons nous en sommes ok
porte partant lui au moment
sa naissance et ma petite fille qui est
magnifique je suis quand comme tous les
grands pères bien sûr la sort alasora un
moment de ça le livre est un dialogue
que le moment de son arrivée sur terre
elle porte en elle la conscience de
l'identité l'homme et les seuls 20 des
prix qui se reconnaît dans l'autre chien
voit un chien battu rien ne se passe si
un homme voit un enfant martyrisé et
c'est on peut avoir est elle à ce qu'ils
soient tous cas pas cas social de
quelques huîtres histoire quelque chose
en lui c'est faux la conscience de
l'identité et consensus en ciel alors il
est recouvert bétonné par la conscience
néolibérale il s'agit de réveiller cette
conscience collectif le taux d'identité
immanuel compte philosophe allemand
enfin 18e jeudi par coup
c'est intelligent culture que tu il
marque ambi l'inhumanité infligé un
autre détruit l'humanité en moi et ça
c'est l'impératif catégorique nous
portons en nous et qui est plus puissant
que 1000 bombes atomiques
et si nous arrivons réveiller cet
impératif catégorique de mettre en route
les gens l'insurrection des consciences
va se créer demain matin vaty free c'est
un cannibale du monde
ouvrir la voix mystérieuse inconnue pour
l'instant
pour une société plus juste heureuse
pour tous bon ça ça fait rêver non rêver
les marchés c'était de pire dans
l'utopie est une force historique c'est
l'horizon que nous portons nous c'est
l'horizon que chacun porte en lui la vie
a un sens
l'histoire un sens ma vie a un sens si
ma vie n'avait pas tant si l'histoire
est vincent il n'avait qu'à se pendre tu
comprends or on est là pour faire
l'histoire en fonction du bonheur qui
nous est promis en fonction justice qui
est que nous sommes capables de réaliser
sur une planète je le redis qui pour la
première fois au début de ce millénaire
a vaincu le manque objectif il ya trois
quatre cinq générations de suisse des
gens des mig et au delà des mers de
l'engadine de 20 min c'est pour fuir
d'autres sous alimentation la misère
aujourd'hui la mise elle sur cette
planète est objectivement vaincu ceux
qui tuent des gens ceux qui créent ces
vides souffrance seguer qui sont des
carnages effroyable comme l'autre cyril
vic sans appliquer une telle foule c'est
inégal puisqu'ils sont des biens
l'accaparement par les oligarchies mince
puissante d'un film en cynique maîtrise
en du bien commun la capnographie
d'immenses richesses au détriment de la
satisfaction des besoins élémentaires de
tous au tout insulté et nous pouvons
faire ce monde nouveau nous sommes dans
un pays libre
nous sommes debout produits
provisoirement très probalement la vie
est un film en cours on devait être
assis mais vous avez vous aider vous et
c'est très bien et still standing
je veux dernier pas une phrase tenir
houda parole du nom d'un grand poète
chilien à musique s'arrêtera gènes des
salvadoriens été assassiné par ses
sauvegardes président du chili
démocratique mais lui ça s'est passé sur
le gardera le 11 septembre 73,5 nehru ya
écrit un point magnifique épique qui
s'appelle el canto general le champ
général l'histoire des peuples
d'amérique latine et se canto general
hermine partenaires dont une côte alto
d'assas flores et laura maes et et dames
la primavera eu nos ennemis vous
regrouper toutes les fleurs mais jamais
ils ne seront les maîtres du printemps
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]